ça fait partie au fond du jeu vous savez
ce qu'on dit au premier tour lors de
l'élection présidentielle on choisit et
lors du deuxième tour on élimine moi
c'est pas ma conception et d'ailleurs je
pense que vu l'état de notre pays et de
ses fractures
vu le rejet d'une manière générale de la
politique je peux pas exagérer les
Français ont quand même voté hier il
faut essayer plutôt de faire adhérer
positivement nos compatriotes les
électeurs à des à des projets celui
d'Emmanuel Macron celui de Marine Le Pen
reconnaissons qu'ils sont quand même
très opposés ils sont aux antipodes donc
au moins les Français sont confrontés un
choix de société un destin pour leur
pays et moi je préfère surtout dans
cette période là avec une participation
qui était plus importante et ça que
prévu même si elle est quand même 25% de
gens oui oui elle est il y a elle est
médiocre de millions de Français qui
n'ont pas voté je n'oublie pas
d'ailleurs ceux qui sont pas inscrit
mais
exactement il faut qu'il faut rajouter
enfin c'est un pays qui vote encore qui
croit contrairement souvent ce qu'on dit
dans dans la politique moi je vous
remercie aussi de permettre à la
politique présente sur ce sur ce plateau
essayons de faire adhérer les Français à
des projets ensuite vous empêcherez
jamais ceux qui mène campagnent contre
une personne des idées une merveille
tout sauf Charcot à un moment il y a eu
François Hollande il a fait lui-même
tout sauf Hollande
moi j'ai souvent dit c'est un confort
c'est un confort pendant des années pour
la gauche tout sauf Sarko puis vous
gagnez des élections locales ça vous
évite de travailler ça vous évite de
réfléchir ça vous évite de bien vous
préparer au pouvoir et quand vous gagnez
vous êtes confronté à la réalité et aux
contradictions de l'exercice du pouvoir
c'est alors peut-être que l'époque je
crois pas mais que l'époque sur les
réseaux sociaux les formes de
confrontation la polarisation le fait
que les gens aiment bien c'est le
confrontation
facilitent cela mais il y a toujours un
vote contre mais à un moment il faut
choisir les gens qui n'ont pas choisi
qui ont voté pour d'autres candidats qui
ne sont pas présents au second tour au
deuxième tour il vote aussi un peu par
par élimination ils choisissent le
moindre mal mais là je pense qu'il y
aura beaucoup aussi de votre blanc c'est
ce que j'entends moi beaucoup de je sais
pas je trouve que côté là comme il y a
pas eu la campagne que beaucoup
souhaitaient avant avant le premier tour
là écoutez là il y a 15 jours c'est pas
mal il va y avoir beaucoup d'interviews
d'entretien j'espère que tout le monde
sera là pour pour
Baba on fera passer tous les tous les
tous les messages et puis il y aura le
débat de de de le débat entre les deux
candidats dans dans quelques jours après
plus d'une semaine bon donc et puis moi
je pense que les Français sont très
intelligents collectivement
il choisit ils écoutent ils regardent
ils vont ils vont se ils vont se
déterminer j'espère mais moi j'ai trouvé
que et pour mon pays
de le faire après je veux dire moi aussi
je trouve que c'est vrai que les
Français et je l'ai dit vous avez
arrêtez pas de leur dire c'est pas voter
pour un tel il faut voter on le voyait
les résultats
ils savent faire une analyse eux-mêmes
de ce qui se passe et de qui il faut et
pour qu'il faut l'aider pour c'est vrai
on le voit par exemple il y a eu
beaucoup et en vrai ce premier tour il
dit quoi il dit qu'il y a eu énormément
de vote utile en fait de votre ultime
sur voilà on le voit l'effondrement de
Valérie Pécresse au détriment d'Emmanuel
Macron mine de rien aussi Éric Zemmour
qu'on appelle
il existe toujours mais jamais je mets y
compris avec Zemmour jamais on a eu
trois candidats avec ses scores au
dessus de de vin il y a eu en 2002 ils
étaient très serré et peut-être et même
en 95 non 95 avant
le premier à 23 là ici c'est c'est c'est
donc il y a eu vraiment quand vous
regardez tous les autres sont en moins
de 7 et surtout en moins de 5 vous voyez
que vraiment la les Français en 2002
j'ose pas il était pas dans le noir non
en 2000 en 95 il était à 23 il était
tombé en 2002 ils étaient tous en
dessous ils étaient tous en dessous
exactement
il a vraiment des Candy à l'extrême
gauche faisait un meilleur score mais je
vous dis pas tout tous les autres bah
mais là donc il y a eu un vote utile
parce que les Français sont utiles sur
Jean-Luc Mélenchon regardez le score
d'Anne Hidalgo et puis les trois
candidats représentent des courants
politiques des idées ou de leur
personnalité qui qui représentent c'est
vrai que on a vraiment pas dans le pays
gauche milieu droite c'est fou c'est
vraiment là et il y a plus de voilà de
et c'est vraiment c'est bien bien défini
c'est surtout disons-le à très nouveau
parce que aux élections locales vous
allez régional et cantonale il y a
encore quelques mois marqué par une
abstention massive c'était encore les
vieux partis implanté socialiste et
sociaux républicain qui avait résisté
parce que c'était les sortants là c'est
la pyramide est totalement inversée les
parties qui ont moins de force ou voire
pas du tout au plan local c'est le cas
de la France insoumise en revanche une
représentation de courant de courant
politique et Jean-Luc Mélenchon vous
savez tous les désaccords qui m'opposent
à lui mais ils sont talent à à
représenter oui
exceptionnelle Jean-Luc voilà on le dit
parce que c'est vrai que voilà il faut
dire les choses quand on est bon on le
dit quand c'est moins bien on le dit
aussi là il a il a remonté je ne sais
pas d'où moi franchement je croyais pas
du tout qu'il a étonné et puis moi ça me
donne ça me donne plein d'espoir vous
rendez compte les trois candidats en
tête sont connus le président sortant
bien évidemment et et Jean-Luc Mélenchon
on est à ça troisième candidature Marine
Le Pen a sa troisième ça doit être
derrière la huitième de la de la famille
Le Pen c'est les gens qui sont dans le
paysage installer connu que les Français
parce que il y a la fois en contractions
[Applaudissements]
de l'élection enfin de la qualification
de d'Emmanuel Macron et de Marine Le Pen
et forcément comme on est très
professionnel on n'a pas votre tweeté
quoi j'ai twitté voté Marine Le Pen
officiel au second tour n'est pas donné
un blanc simple c'est juste dire non à
l'extrémisme l'extrême mépris l'extrême
pauvreté dans laquelle va nous plonger
un quinquennat Macron l'extrême copinage
l'extrême-onction de la France c'est
rentrer dans un premier temps
pourquoi tout sauf Macron
expliquer nous
pour les raisons que j'ai exposé
on sort d'un quinquennat Macron qui a
été il faut être honnête dévastateur
alors je comprends que Monsieur Valls
puisse pas l'entendre puisqu'il n'était
pas là donc forcément juger un
quinquennat d'un président de la
République bah c'est vrai le fait que
vous étiez à Barcelone et moi aussi
probablement que j'aurais apprécié le
quinquennat Macron en tout cas je leur
ai moins détesté si j'avais pas eu le
subir si vous voulez dès lors
effectivement moi le tout sauf Macron il
est très clair il est pas un blanc sain
de la marine la Pen dans la mesure où si
Jean-Luc Mélenchon avait été élu enfin
avait été en tout cas être au second
tour quoi j'aurais également dit la même
chose aujourd'hui si vous voulez très
clairement on peut pas se permettre le
luxe d'un quinquennat qui va mettre les
Français dans la rue parce que nous
sommes dans un gouvernement qui a été le
gouvernement du mépris qui a été le
gouvernement des petites phrases qui
étaient le gouvernement moi j'aurais
aimé pouvoir dire écoutez j'aurais mis
d'abord de ne pas faire ce tweet en
disant bon Emmanuel Macron a été ce
qu'il est il a pris conscience d'un
certain nombre de d'erreurs ainsi
commises et peut-être de ligne franchie
dans le mépris en fait des Français on
fait quand même on est quand même en
plein scandale McKinsey ça interroge
d'ailleurs ça interroge le point de
savoir si au moment où Emmanuel Macron
est un ministre de l'Économie sous le
gouvernement de Monsieur Valls mackinsey
était déjà présent dans le gouvernement
nous avons laissé les clés si vous
voulez du gouvernement français un
cabinet de conseil condamné aux
États-Unis pour des faits d'une extrême
gravité c'est un scandale qui a valu
moins que ça a valu la campagne à
François Fillon en 2017 donc les APL ont
été réformés par un cabinet de conseils
vous avez vous êtes rendu compte que
dans ce quinquennat vous n'aviez
finalement qu'un quinquennat du copinage
et du mépris que tout ce qui a été
décidé il a été les classes moyennes se
sont appauvris les classes populaires se
sont appauvris ça a été vous avez vu les
gilets jaunes on a eu enfin une
répression sans égal les non vaccinés
qu'il faut emmerder mais attention il a
dit maintenant chaleureusement ou
amicalement a-t-il dit donc maintenant
voilà qu'un président de la République
oh merde amicalement une partie de la
population
devrait pas dire ça
il a raison Fabrice division pas je
crois qu'il est en train de faire la
campagne d'Emmanuel Macron parce que
vous avez dit tout à l'heure pour
l'autre débat tout ce qui exagéré tout
ce qui est sur tout tout tout ce que
vous dites mais tout cabinet de conseils
exagéré monsieur Valls le ton le dire
que vous étiez en France c'est 5 ans non
excusez-moi monsieur Valls mais vous
venez effectivement juger moi mais c'est
quand même important excusez-moi c'est
important
non mais vous comprenez bien que quand
même vous venez soutenir un candidat que
vous avez fui en partant à l'étranger
c'est quand même singulier de venir
défendre le bilan de quelqu'un sous
lequel vous n'avez pas voulu rester
monsieur je vous vois très très je vois
avec une rage ou en tout cas une colère
des Français monsieur celle que vous
pouvez pas là vous vous représentez-vous
comme moi je représente moi c'est déjà
pas mal pour représentez pas les
Français je vous sens un peu illuminés
je vais vous dire attendez on m'a posé
une question je suis pas venu pour vous
interrompre on va pas s'interrompre on
va essayer d'avoir
on va savoir un débat dit que j'étais
venu ici il y a quelques mois déjà
répondre aux questions de de Cyril et
des chroniqueurs et j'avais dit
d'ailleurs si j'étais parti c'est rien à
voir avec le Macron c'est pour des
raisons personnelles parce que j'étais
parti j'étais en train de l'amour crever
une certaine manière je conduis à un an
euh le débat c'est pas moi bon et puis
je peux regarder les choses on peut lire
on peut regarder on peut vivre des
enfants mes amis ma famille vivre dans
ce pays donc jouons pas là-dessus jouons
pas
non mais je suis obligé
monsieur j'ai vécu cinq ans à l'étranger
moi-même en l'occurrence effectivement
je vous assure j'étais à Rome pendant 5
ans et je vous garantis une chose c'est
que
ce qui se passe en France entendre ce
qui se passe en France ou vivre ce qui
se passe en France si la propriété
présent monsieur boulouriez mais je suis
j'étais député jusqu'à la fin 2018 et je
suis là depuis un an donc déjà avec ça
je peux me faire une idée mais j'ai
l'impression que le débat c'était pas
moi et et je peux avoir un avis d'autant
plus que je suis engagé déjà depuis
plusieurs mois et en écrivant et en
prenant la parole on a ici et désormais
on soutenant Emmanuel Macron de nouveau
donc moi on peut critiquer on peut
mettre en cause que le pays soit facturé
qui a eu la crise des gilets jaunes que
le pays a fait face à des problèmes
c'est vrai et de l'autre côté on peut
dire bon chômage a baissé des impôts ont
baissé le président Macron gère les
crises et notamment la dernière
géostratégique par rapport à l'Ukraine
avec je crois du leadership et sur la
question de la pandémie de la covid 19
bon il s'était très difficile comme dans
tous les pays comme dans tous les pays
mais à la fin bon il y a des choses qui
ont été faites et notamment le quoi
qu'il en coûte et et et les campagnes
vaccinales de ces derniers mois ce que
je veux dire par là c'est que avec en
tout cas pas d'exaltation et et de
l'expérience je pense qu'on peut essayer
de convaincre les Français avec les
meilleurs arguments alors parlant au
cœur parce que ça compte dans une
campagne la sensibilité le rapport d'un
homme d'une femme d'une personnalité
avec le peuple mais aussi avec des
arguments et c'est au nom de ces
arguments moi que je défends la
candidature d'Emmanuel Macron et c'est
au nom d'arguments que je combats celle
de Marine Le Pen mais ce que j'ai
compris c'est que la diabolisation ou
l'appel aux fascisme ou pour la contrer
ou ou le ou le tout sauf Marine Le Pen
ça ne va pas une question mentale moi je
pense qu'il faut être dans
l'argumentation sur l'alimentation voilà
ne vous inquiétez guère on va être
démontage
de ce pas nous allons dans
l'argumentation nous vous en inquiétez
pas je veux dire que ma question que je
voudrais quand même vous poser
on doit faire 20 minutes pour Marine Le
Pen
je vous vois avec beaucoup de non pas du
tout mais ma question est fort simple
monsieur est-ce que aujourd'hui est-ce
que on est d'accord pour dire que vous
monsieur Macron est impliqué dans un
scandale sans précédent avec un casino
c'est Nicolas pernicov qui parle ou
c'est moi c'est toujours indiqué
dans le débat avec les chroniqueurs que
savez-vous de la faire McKinsey mais je
m'en fous aujourd'hui je m'en fous dans
les entre deux tours aujourd'hui on a
deux candidats ce qu'il faut parler
d'arguments
alors argumentaire
sur un point c'est que pour l'instant
effectivement en l'occurrence vous ne
demandez pas pourquoi je vote Marine Le
Pen vous me demandez de m'expliquer sur
le tout sauf Macron j'essaye de faire on
le jouvence
tout sauf Macron j'essaye de vous
expliquer que notamment lorsqu'un
candidat est à ce point impliqué dans
une affaire qui relève du scandale
d'État ne vous en déplaise car monsieur
vous ignorez qui est McKinsey c'est une
question ça me fait rire mais ça Ann ça
nous fait rire qu'un cabinet de conseils
j'avais terminé
et je pourrais même vous lire un email
que vous m'avez envoyé dans lequel vous
dites en substance que vous cherchez à
tous les moyens pour être connus et donc
vous êtes ridicule et vous montez
systématiquement vous devriez venir aux
Français
votre proximité d'ailleurs avec
l'extrême droite devrait faire que votre
temps de parole est déconté je pense que
vous avez du sel de mentir est-ce que
vous pourriez juste m'expliquer qu'il y
a making c'est alors non seulement vous
avez menti systématiquement mais je ne
voulais pas question mais vous n'êtes
pas
nous sommes là pour un débat d'idée à
ton dit mais vous me disiez on en avait
aucune non mais vous avez fait
[Rires]
[Musique]
effectivement avec mackenza vous n'avez
pas pouvoir vous faire d'argent je
comprends qu'il y a un business
intéressant
[Rires]
quand on a un débat politique on a
tendance à prendre les choses pour soi
on peut avoir un débat vous l'avez
d'ailleurs ici j'imagine sur la question
de ces cabinets de conseils
mais c'était pas le sujet Macron
[Rires]
qui est ouverte notamment sur le fait
que cette entreprise le paierait pas je
parle au conditionnel puisque l'enquête
est ouverte ne paierait pas d'impôts
mais si vous voulez c'est si on rentrait
dans ce débat si si moi je vais
participer au débat précédent et j'avais
rappelé par exemple
tous les problèmes financiers de Madame
Le Pen on m'aurait dit à juste titre un
vieux débat il y a 20 ans Emmanuel
Macron
Emmanuel Macron n'est pas concerné le
président de la République il aille
d'ailleurs lui-même le l'occasion de
s'exprimer laissez vous êtes avocat je
crois que vous m'avez dit laissez la
justice laisser la justice laissez la
justice agir laissez la justice ça se
travaille ça viendra soyez calme vous
énervez pas les décisions tomberont
elles sont intimes
donc je vais vous dire nous sommes dans
une démocratie nous sommes un pays
d'État droit donc il faut moi je vous
lis moi aussi j'étais jeune
je suis sidéré par l'immense hypocrisie
de mettre division quoi alors c'est pas
ça c'est parce que il est pas chose
avec des dossiers immenses sur le covid
tout ça n'était qu'une fumisterie et
vous nous avez manipulé et vous avez
manipulé des millions de gens on peut
avoir un débat parce que vos dossiers ça
signifie
intelligent que j'aurais aimé répondre
plutôt content de ça j'aurais préféré
répondre aux propos intelligent de
Monsieur
vous fouiller dès que ça bouffé
je pense que les Français
du spectacle c'était pour préparer votre
ralliement à Marine Le Pen vous faites
ce que vous voulez mais vous nous avez
bidonné sur le vaccin sur l'épidémie sur
tout ça au nom de votre idéologie et ça
je vous en veux beaucoup parce que
parfois dans quelques débats rarement je
vous ai trouvé sincère et pertinent et
tout ça c'était de l'hypocrisie mais
Maître division mettre division vous me
décevez vous me décevez rien vous
n'imaginez pas je déçois Gilbert je me
remettrai pas voilà effectivement ça
c'est une lumière même pas dit ça tout
hein
ok alors maintenant peut-être pouvoir
reprendre un petit peu le débat de
qualité que nous avions
de parole non ce qui m'étonne monsieur
Valls voyez-vous je le redis avec une
assistance c'est que vous parliez de
fracture tout à l'heure et à raison
qu'il y a une fracture mais il y a une
fracture non peut-être oui effectivement
mais en l'occurrence le pays on a des
multiples de fractures et ces fractures
elles ont été exactement provoquer et
aggraver en tout cas par le quinquennat
mais je comprends fort aisément que vous
n'en soyez pas d'accord et cependant
effectivement c'est un fait que cette
crise des gilets jaunes quand même le
pays est descendu dans la rue pour un
gasoil à nous sommes à plus nous sommes
à 1 euro de plus aujourd'hui les APL la
réforme des aPL monsieur Valls on
apprend aujourd'hui qu'elle a été
conduite par un de ces cabinet de
conseils dont vous semblez penser que
c'est un détail pour vous c'est un
détail mais peut-être que Monsieur pour
les Français ça l'est pas le détail
peut-être que les 50 % de Français qui
ont voté qui n'ont pas voté pour
Emmanuel Macron peut-être que pour eux
c'est pas grave c'est peut-être un
détail pour vous
dire beaucoup France Gall effectivement
ce que je trouve monsieur Valls de
finalement surprenant c'est que votre
constat est juste sur le la question des
fractures et tout ça m'a évoqué ensemble
simplement ce qui me surprend encore un
peu c'est que vous voyez faire un mec à
coule pas d'Emmanuel Macron sur son
bilan disant il y a eu des problèmes on
a eu effectivement j'ai jamais vu sur ce
point il y a eu effectivement des
fractures sur ce point que j'ai senti
provoquer peut-être à volontairement
peut-être mais quand même quand vous
avez un quand vous avez un président de
la République Monsieur aujourd'hui vous
avez 15000 soignants qui sont suspendus
sans salaire palier par heure
automatique de la de la de la des
républicains qui sont effectivement des
choux
c'est que vous aviez 20 % si vous voulez
de François Fillon à l'époque vous avez
préféré on va répondre avec Manuel Valls
ils se sont exprimés au premier tour
s'expriment au deuxième tour la réalité
c'est que Emmanuel Macron a fait plus de
voix et un pourcentage plus élevé que la
dernière fois Marine Le Pen aussi bon
ils sont confrontés
au second tour moi oui bien sûr qu'il y
a les fractures elles sont territoriales
elles sont sociales elles sont même
générationnelles elles sont donc
géographiques ça a été analysé depuis
des années et pourquoi Emmanuel Macron a
été élu sans doute parce que ses
factures sociales et politiques étaient
arrivés à tel point qu'on a rejeté me
semble on a rejeté le système politique
lui il a dû faire face c'est aussi l'une
des raisons pour lesquelles je le
soutiens à des crises majeures sociales
les gilets jaunes suivies d'un d'un
grand débat la pandémie brica qui a pas
touché que que la France avec en plus
une confrontation en France ça je l'ai
observé de l'extérieur là vous avez
raison d'ailleurs avec des personnalités
des personnages comme vous qui me
paraissaient sur ces sujets là le mot
exagéré est faible mais dans dans pas
seulement dans la démagogie mais dans un
danger dans une tromperie par rapport à
nos compatriotes plus la crise plus
parler de tromperie fallait vraiment que
je sois là pour le moment
sur ce sujet là exceptionnel sur ce
sujet
là sur ce sujet là vous avez raconté des
choses franchement les messieurs très
particuliers monsieur je termine
le problème j'en termine on balance des
accusations comme Monsieur tout à
l'heure je termine le message
j'ai pas ici pour vous les Français
moi j'ai vu les images tout à l'heure et
il a rencontré
sur l'école sur la gestion de la covid
sur sur les retraites et d'ailleurs je
fais une remarque en passant moi je vois
pas beaucoup d'images en général big
Marine Le Pen fait campagne mais je la
vois pas beaucoup avec les gens avec les
avec les vrais gens comme on dit le soir
alors elle le sera mercredi chez le
frère
donc merci Cyril alors là c'est
exceptionnel j'ai un prix d'un soutien
de de alors là c'est merci Monsieur
franchement merci entièrement hein ça
m'inquiète j'ai appris j'ai appris tout
à l'heure donc finalement
il y avait une tromperie qui Emmanuel
Macron nous trompe d'Emmanuel Macron
parler de tromperie j'ai dit combien je
trouvais ça exceptionnel mais maintenant
voici qu'Emmanuel Macron rencontre les
vrais gens mais monsieur effectivement
vous êtes bien longtemps merci merci
en tout cas merci Manuel Valls
je vous assure monsieur je suis une
vraie je vais vous dire Monsieur je vais
vous dire Monsieur qui depuis 5 ans est
emmerdé par son président de la
République
vous vous êtes beaucoup hein
merci
beaucoup de monde